[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed now just
let me get this off my chest
i was wrong
well sort of i did grossly underestimate
how powerful these new turing gpus would
be and well i'm the first to admit that
i didn't stress at the time that i was
only guessing while making a number of
assumptions and you know what they say
about those
but i was pretty confident my claims
i think i was allowing the high prices
which really annoyed me at the time uh
the one month pre-order period
and all the faffing about overrate
racing all that stuff to sort of cloud
my judgment a bit and i did jump the gun
on a few things having said that in my
defense you know defend myself ever so
slightly but i admit i was very much
wrong on the performance claims but i
did have your best interests at heart uh
the theme in that video was don't
pre-order play it safe make an informed
purchase after all these aren't exactly
cheap graphics cards and i wasn't
exactly wrong for questioning how much
value they would ultimately offer but as
i said the performance claims were a bit
off i was actually miles off on my rtx
2080 claim which is
quite interesting
and possibly more interesting is the
fact that i wasn't that far off on my
rtx 2080 ti performance claim
so
that's probably going to disappoint a
few of you anyway enough about that for
now let's get to the results because i
know you've had enough speculation leaks
slides from nvidia and even official
information regarding specifications and
pricing so rather than go over any of
that i'm just going to get straight into
the benchmarks starting with a few quick
words on the test system as usual i'm
using a corsair gpu test system built
inside the crystal series 570x with a
core i7 8700k clocked at five gigahertz
with 32 gigabytes of vengeance ddr4 3400
memory for the amd gpus i've used the
radeon adrenaline edition 18.9.1 driver
and for nvidia the geforce
399.24 driver while the new geforce rtx
20 series gpus we'll be using driver
version 411.51
in total we have a dozen games to go
over along with a few other tests then
tomorrow we will unleash a mega 35 game
benchmark
okay let's get to the results
starting with the battlefield 114 40p
results we see that the rtx 2080 is able
to deliver gtx today ti like performance
initially i was worried the 2080 would
be slower than the 1080 ti placing it
somewhere between the 1080 and 1080 ti
thankfully though it is better than that
and we see it delivering 27 more
performance on the gtx 1080 when
comparing the average frame rate and 23
more for the frame time result
the 2080 ti is an absolute beast here
beating both the 2080 and 1080 ti by
over a 25 margin pretty incredible stuff
but let's move on to 4k to see what
happens there
here the gtx 2080 like the 1082i was
able to provide player performance
rendering 24
more frames on average when compared to
amd's radio on vega 64 liquid
but it was the 2080 ti that again blew
us away with an incredible 100 fps on
average at 4k in battlefield 1 using the
ultra quality settings in fact the frame
time performance of the 2080 ti was
higher than that of the 1080 ti's
average frame rate so that's pretty
incredible
moving on to far cry 5 and again we see
it the rtx 2080 is able to mirror the
gtx 1080 ti's performance with 112 fps
on average making it 27 faster than the
gtx 1080. as for the 2080 ti that pushed
the average frame rate out to 132 fps
but we are clearly running into a system
bottleneck here as the frame time
performance is similar to that of the
1080 ti who would have thought that at
1440p using ultra quality settings that
are five gigahertz all core 8700k
overclock would be holding things up
moving to 4k relieves the system
bottleneck and now the 28dti is 28
faster than the 1080ti on average and 25
faster for the frame time result the
2080 is also 30 faster than the gtx 1080
so another impressive result there that
said while the 2080 does average 61 fps
you will notice dips
slightly below that of course it is
still very playable but it's not as
silky smooth as the experience seen when
using the 2080 ti
that is truly breathtaking
next up we have armor 3 a title that's
always heavily requested here we see it
1440p that we're certainly not gpu bound
it's quite clear that there's some other
kind of system bottleneck or possibly
even a limitation of the game itself
so we'll have to move to 4k to see what
the new rtx gpus can offer
right so at 4k we only see a slight drop
in performance for the 2080 ti when
compared to the 1440p numbers just seen
this means it's now 30 faster than the
2080 and 1080 ti meanwhile the 2080 is
35 faster than the gtx 1080 and that is
a pretty serious margin right there
moving along we have some grand theft
auto 5 results and again i know this is
a seriously old title but it's still
very popular and you guys seem to
absolutely lose your mind if i don't
include it so in an effort to keep the
peace here are the results also please
note the game has been maxed out
including all the advanced graphical
settings despite that though we are
seeing a pretty heavy system bottleneck
at 1440p so the results here are
somewhat useless though they do inform
us that if you are a massive gta 5 fan
and you only play at 1440p then the rtx
series won't really provide a noticeable
performance boost
once again it is the 4k resolution that
helps separate the rtxs from the gtx's
here the 2080 ti was 37 faster than the
1080 ti and that's a seriously nice gain
we also see that 2080 roughly matched
the 1080 ti placing it well ahead of the
vanilla 1080 so an amazing result here
hitman is yet another title that sees us
somewhat cpu limited at 1440p i see the
2080ti was just 8 faster than the 1080
ti so let's move to 4k to see if the
more extreme resolution helps shift the
focus towards the gpu once again it is
the 4k resolution that helps separate
the rtx's from the gtx's here the 2080
ci was 24 faster than the 1080i a decent
performance jump but not really enough
to justify the price increase meanwhile
the 2080 roughly matched the 1080 ti
making it 30 faster than the standard
1080 which is actually quite an
impressive result
for the first time ever no man's sky has
found its way into our benchmarks quite
a few viewers request that we test with
the title since it has been updated
apparently now it is actually pretty
good
performance with the new rtx graphics
cards isn't bad either the 2080 was a
smidgen faster than the 1080i and this
meant it was a whopping 49 faster than
the 1080.
then at the very top of our graph we of
course have the new rtx 2080 ti which
offered a 25 performance bump over the
standard 2080. increasing the resolution
to 4k helped the 2080 ti extend its lead
ever so slightly over the 2080 now it's
27 faster meanwhile the 2080 beat the
1080 by a slightly less impressive 14
margin
the results seen when testing with
project cars 2 aren't as impressive as
we're expecting and here we don't appear
to be running into any kind of system
bottleneck the 2080 ti was just 18
faster than the 1080 ti and the 2080
just 21 faster than the 1080. apologies
for all 1080 and 2080s in this video but
there's really no way of getting around
it
anyway hopping up to the 4k resolution
did nothing to help out the 2080 ti here
it was less than 20 faster than the 1080
ti while the 2080 was now just 19 faster
than the 1080. this could merely be a
driver issue or it could be that turing
isn't able to leverage the integer cores
in this title
next up we have rainbow six siege and
this title has always leveraged the
radeon gpus very well here we see vega
56 matching the gtx 1080 and beating the
1070 ti something it doesn't often do
turing does seem to correct this and
here we are seeing some pretty stellar
gains over pascal even at 1440p here the
2080 ti was almost 40 percent faster
than the 1080 ti
while the 2080 is 51 faster than the
1080.
those are some serious gains and we see
them continue at 4k as the 2080 ti is
now 51 faster than the 1080 ti
and the 2080 52 faster than the 1080
again those are some seriously
impressive gains right there i was
shocked to see 145 fps on average at 4k
from the 2080 ti that is just
mind-bending performance
another new title that we're
benchmarking for the first time is
shadow of the tomb raider and what an
incredibly amazing looking game this one
is
you'll certainly want to dial up the eye
candy and with the new rtx graphics
cards that's not really a problem here
we see the 2080 again matched the 1080
ti at 1440p while the 2080 ti was 24
faster hitting 107 fps
even at 4k the performance provided by
the 2080 ti is pretty unbelievable 59
fps on average with a one percent lower
result of 50 fps in a game that looks
this good that's an incredible result
and if you drop the preset just one
level to higher the average frame rate
jumps up to 80 fps with a one percent
low result of over 60 fps so again
really impressive performance at the 4k
resolution the 2080 also does quite well
though like the 1080 ti you will at
times notice the slight dip in frame
rates but i am of course being quite
picky and after all these certainly
aren't cheap graphics cards strange
brigade is a recently released title
that we've already benchmarked quite
extensively on the channel here we see
the rtx 2080 matches the 1080 ti at
1440p and this made it 36 faster than
the gtx 1080. as impressive as 125 fps
on average is the 2080 ti absolutely
blew that away with 163 fps making it 28
faster than the 1080 ti
that margin is slightly reduced to 4k
down to 27 but that still makes the 2080
ti by far the fastest gpu in this test
pushing 94 fps on average the 2080 also
managed 69 fps on average with a one
percent lower result of 59 fps so it
also allowed for a nice smooth gaming
experience at 4k
the second last game we're going to look
at is vermintide 2 and here the 2082 i
rented 133 fps on average 1440p making
it 25 faster than the 1080 ti and 2080.
meanwhile the 2080 was almost 40 percent
faster than the 1080 so a pretty big
step forward there vermintide 2 looks
quite exceptional at 4k and playing on
an rtx 2080 ti with over 60fps at all
times was a bit special it's an
expensive experience but damn does it
look good it's only 24 fast on the gtx
1080 ti but it makes a massive
difference to gameplay the 2080 was also
just 17 faster than 1080 but again that
made a huge difference to how well the
game played
finally the last game that we're going
to check out in this review is
wolfenstein 2 the new colossus and
wow
just wow
nvidia has focused on improving their
async compute performance and the
results here just speak for themselves
okay so the 2080 ti is averaging
273 fps at 1440p using the maximum
in-game quality settings
you'd be forgiven for thinking that
wolfenstein 2 must look like fortnite
this made the 2080 ti 41 faster than the
1080 ti while the 2080 was 49 percent
faster than the 1080
however those margins are further
extended at 4k here the 2080 ti is seen
to be 55 faster than the 1080 ti that
said the 2080 maintains a similar lead
over the 1080 as they were less cpu
limited at the lower 1440p resolution
but seriously can i just say wow one
more time bloody hell 170 fps on average
at 4k
i mean the 1080 ti was already
blistering fast in this title but 170
fps with a one percent low of 152 fps
holy moly that's fast
of course you can make the 2080 ti a
little bit faster by overclocking it
though as was the case with pascal they
are pretty well tapped out it was
possible to increase the gddr6 memory
frequency by 650 megahertz and the core
by 190 megahertz this resulted in an
average operating frequency of 1940
megahertz for the cause when gaming the
vanilla 2080 accepted the same 650
megahertz for the memory but 120
megahertz for the cause as the cores are
clocked a little higher by default this
resulted in an average core clock
frequency of 2150 megahertz when gaming
ultimately what all this means is you're
able to squeeze about nine percent more
frames out of the 2080 and five percent
more out of the 2080 ti when testing
with shadow of the tomb raider
not mind-blowing but it is extra
performance for free
the 2080 ti again saw a five percent
boost from the overclock at this time
when testing with strange brigade
meanwhile the 2080 saw a similar 7 boost
to performance again not amazing but
it's better than a sharp stick in the
eye moving on here is an overview of the
2080ti and 2080 foundation graphics
cards both stock and overclocked as you
can see the operating temperatures only
increased by five degrees when
overclocked and we saw a six to twelve
percent increase in fan speed i should
note that the operating volumes for the
founders edition models were very low
the cards are basically silent when
installed in the system even at 2200 rpm
the dual fans can barely be heard so
quality wise the fe cards are good but
we still don't recommend you buy them
given that they cost more than the aib
models and cards from msi asus gigabyte
and so on are likely to be as good if
not better
the average operating frequency of the
2080 ti was increased by 11
and the 2080 by 12 but of course we've
already looked at the resulting
performance the gddr6 memory also ran at
7 650 megahertz once overclocked for a
throughput of 15.3 gigabits per second
oh and i almost forgot power consumption
we should probably touch on that the rtx
2080 ti is a bit of a power peak pushing
total system consumption up towards 500
watts which is vega 64 liquid territory
of course in terms of efficiency it is
worlds better and i think we can accept
this kind of power consumption given the
resulting performance after all total
system consumption was only up 15
percent from the 1080 ti
then we see that the rtx 2080 system
configuration consumed 20 less power
when compared to the gtx 1080 ti which
is a reasonable improvement given it
delivers comparable performance okay so
we've now looked at performance in a
dozen games and if you think the choice
of titles seemed a bit odd a bit random
please know that it's neither of those
things and in tomorrow's video it will
be a lot clearer as to why i chose the
titles that i did for this video i also
only briefly touched on overclocking i
really didn't go into any depth there at
all just showed a few performance
numbers and the frequencies that i got
to which i'm pretty sure are the maximum
frequencies that my cards could do
without any really serious
modifications but anyway tim will be
following up on the channel the next few
days with some more in-depth
overclocking content overclocking guides
perhaps all that sort of stuff
but anyway for now we need to finish
this review so let's take a closer look
at the performance breakdown we did
often find that the 2080 ti was cpu
bound at 1440p so unsurprisingly here it
is just 23 faster than the 1080 ti on
average that said we do see examples of
it providing games in excess of 30
with rainbow six siege and wolfenstein
being the standouts
here we see the same batch of tests run
at 4k extends the lead out to 31
so on average the 2080 ti is 31 faster
than the 1080 ti according to our
results
the most notable change here is grand
theft auto 5. previously the 2080 ti was
just one percent faster as the system
was heavily limiting performance but now
at 4k it is able to provide 37 more
performance again wolfenstein 2 is the
standout result for the 2080 ti but it
also does well in rainbow six siege and
no man's sky
comparing the 2080 ti and 2080 at 1440p
provides similar results to what was
seen when comparing the 2080 ti and 1080
ti here the 2080 ti beats the standard
version by a 21 margin on average the
margin is extended to 30 at 4k and again
this is because the 2080 ti isn't
limited by other components in the
system the 2080 ti packs 48 more
criticals than the 2080 so a 30
performance uplift on average is what
you'd probably expect to see
now looking at the rtx 2080 we see that
when compared to the 1080 ti it was just
one percent faster on average at 1440p
it's only notable wins came in rainbow
six siege and wolfenstein too while it
was slower by a five percent margin or
more in hitman and project cars too the
margin remains much the same at 4k and
so do the performance trends so overall
the 2080 is offering 1080 ti light
performance
when compared to the gtx 1080 the new
2080 was 29 faster on average at 1440p
which isn't bad and slightly better than
the 23 gain the 2080 ti provided over
the 1080 ti
then finally 4k the 2080 offered 34 more
performance which is certainly a very
respectable gain but then i suppose it
really comes down to how they stack up
in terms of cost per frame so let's look
at that now
okay so we're going to actually make a
few cost per frame comparisons based on
the 4k results just seen first let's
look strictly at aib msrps that is the
suggested retail price for nvidia's
board parts like msi gigabyte and asus
for example added to the model names on
the graphs axis are the msrps so one
thousand dollars u.s for the rtx 2080 ti
for example this means the 2080 ti comes
at a cost of 10.75 cents per frame based
on the performance just seen that figure
alone means nothing but when compared to
the 1080 ti it means you're paying a
nine percent premium for the new
flagship gpu so although the msrp has
increased by 43
given the additional performance you're
only paying nine percent more but of
course that's not really how we should
look at this given that pascal is now a
two-year-old architecture but i will
discuss that more later
the rtx 2080 comes in at a cost of 9.58
per frame and that makes it just four
percent more costly than the gtx 1080
and three percent cheaper than the gtx
1080 ti so that actually seems pretty
good and by all accounts it is i mean
it's not exactly great progress as
you're effectively paying gtx 1080 ti
money for gtx 1080 ti performance
and well we've had that for like a year
and a half now and it's worth noting
that the situation gets much worse if we
price in the founders edition models the
2080 fe costs as much as an aib 2080 ti
per frame and then the 1200 us 2080 ti
comes in at a staggering 12.90 per frame
31 more than the 1080 ti but yet again
it gets even worse than that because
you're forced to pay the fe premium on
all geforce 20 series cards so that
being the case let's take a look at the
current market prices
this is what you can currently expect to
pay for an rtx 2080 and 2080 ti and it's
pretty brutal the 2080 comes in at a
cost of 11.50
per frame making it worse value than
vegas 64. and 20 more costly than a gtx
1080 ti again for the same performance
the 2080 ti is basically a breakeven
scenario it's about 30 percent fast on
the gtx 1080i and it costs about 35 more
per frame
of course you will want to be able to
use all that extra performance as it
costs almost 80 more up front
it's meant to be
something else that i'm supposed to
cover in this review what am i
forgetting
it's meant to be some other big
advantage of buying these new nvidia
geforce rtx graphics cards
oh silly meets in the name isn't it ray
tracing
the rtx 2080 ti packs 10 giga rays per
second of ray tracing performance
and right now you can utilize a total of
zero giga rays per second
considering how much noise nvidia has
made about this technology having spent
the vast majority of the geforce 20
series announcement talking about
nothing else
it's pretty shocking that every gamer
who ordered one after seeing that
amazing star wars demo that was
basically running on a supercomputer
mind you
can't actually use the technology in any
of their favorite games in fact right
now we're waiting on a windows 10 update
which is scheduled for release next
month before it's even possible to use
the technology at all but of course we
also need games and frankly the list of
games advertised to include ray tracing
at this point is
pretty underwhelming currently the list
includes less than a dozen games and
they make up maybe a quarter of the
hotly anticipated titles that will be
released over the next year also i'm
going to risk making an assumption again
and that assumption is that most gamers
aren't a fan of all games so chances are
there's only a couple of titles coming
out over the next 12 months or so that
support ray tracing that you'll actually
want to play one of the best looking
games is shadow of the tomb raider which
can't actually support ray tracing till
next month at the earliest at which
point most of you who want to play that
game will have played that game so going
back and playing it again just to check
out ray tracing makes it more of a tech
demo at that point so it seems as we
suspected nvidia made a heap of noise
about rage racing to justify the crazy
high prices of these new gpus it's
unlikely that many of you will want to
or will be able to take advantage of ray
tracing with the new geforce 20 series
gpus of course at this point that's just
speculation on my behalf we will just
have to wait and see but already the
games list is a pretty strong indicator
that i'm probably not wrong on this one
dlss or deep learning super sampling is
another exciting new feature that we
just can't test out yet outside of a few
demos and while the list of supported
games is more extensive it is also
rather limited so again this is a bit of
a and see situation when it comes to our
reviews here at harbor unboxed we really
only like to make recommendations based
on the facts that we have at hand
which is why we were a little hesitant
to recommend verizon initially as it
wasn't really clear how long it would be
before those extra cores would prove
useful for gamers in the case of these
new geforce rtx graphics cards we can
only base our assessment on the games
tested as well as the current market
prices
and well
that being the case these new geforce
graphics cards in my opinion are a bit
of a tough sell and frankly if i'd
pre-ordered an rtx 2080
i'd be seriously considering cancelling
that pre-order right now it has to be
said the rtx 2080 makes a little sense
that the 700 aib msrp
it's okay i guess
basically it's a few percentage points
better than a gtx 1080 ti and while the
gains are impressive and tile such as
rainbow six siege and wolfenstein too
for the most part the gains are very
small and we will better illustrate this
in tomorrow's 35 game benchmark so as i
said earlier after a year and a half
we're getting gtx 1080 ti like
performance for gtx 1080 ti money but
then that's not even true is it we're
getting gtx 1080ti light performance for
a 20 price hike and then the hope that
ray tracing won't be a complete bust for
this generation so after a year and a
half of gaming with the gtx 1080 ti
color me rather unimpressed
but we do have the extremely impressive
rtx 2080 ti the sock blower i lost so
many pairs of socks benchmarking this
thing in a few dozen games that i've had
to restock my draw it is a mighty
impressive gpu in terms of performance
as we saw it was on average 31 faster
than the already fast gtx 1080 ti
so finally 4k high quality gaming on a
single graphics card is now a reality
but it's a reality you'll probably need
a second job to enjoy
at the one thousand dollar aib msrp it's
not too bad
as crazy as that sounds you're still
paying a premium but it's less than 10
over the 1080 ti
however at the current market price it's
a bad joke 35 premium over the 1080 ti
no thank you nvidia if you've got money
to burn then i guess the rtx 2080 ti can
be justified because well you're not
really needing to justify anything after
all the 4k 144hz gaming monitor starts
at 2 000
so i guess dropping 1200 on a graphics
card to make use of that won't really be
an issue
for the rest of us it's just not worth
touching amd's vegas 64 is horrible
value and yet you'll be paying even more
per frame for an rtx 2080 and 2080 ti
so
that's probably all you really need to
know horrible pricing aside though i am
in awe of the performance these new gpus
can achieve particularly the rtx 2080 ti
its 4k gaming performance really is
unbelievably awesome even so despite
being completely wowed by the rtx 2080
ti
and having admitted that i was wrong
with my guesstimates at the start of
this video as to how these cards were
performed i don't really regret being
cautious i'd probably rather that i
didn't speculate at all because that's
something we almost never do here at
harbour unboxed
but if i had to which i have so there's
no going back on that now uh i'm glad i
was well under or not yeah i'm glad i
was under i was 10
under for the
the rtx 2080 ti and i'm glad i wasn't 10
over because that might have prompted
some of you guys to pre-order and now
you can make an informed buying decision
that being the case if you were going to
pull a trigger on let's say the rtx 2080
or either of them really but this is the
one i'm probably most disappointed
because at least this one
although the pricing's even worse it
enables something that no other product
does so
there's some
you can kind of justify the premium i
suppose but anyway let's not get into
that if you're going to pre-order this
card or you're going to wait for the
reviews and buy it
have the reviews changed your mind in
any way or are you now
on your way to buy an rtx 2080 let me
know in the comment section down below
because as always i am very keen to hear
your thoughts and with that i am going
to end this video because i am
absolutely knackered i don't even know
how many days we spent on this content
piece or i spent on it tim's about to
get busy because these cards are heading
his way but yeah it was a fun but
grueling couple of days of benchmarking
and putting this content together
so i hope you did enjoy it if you did
feel free to like button for us we
greatly appreciate that subscribe for
more content because you are not going
to want to miss what we have coming on
the channel tomorrow because that's the
main reason why i haven't done much
sleeping
and then after that you might have
noticed uh this little guy this little
graphics card here
[Music]
it's a the new msi gaming trio or what
is it the the gaming x trio forgot the x
you've got to get the x in there
but uh
it's kind of a big graphics card it's
kind of a big rtx 2080 ti and it's
possibly
one of the best the best one you can
money can buy it certainly
certainly dwarfs the uh
foundation card i thought this thing was
heavy but not it's not heavy not heavy
at all it's quite light in fact so yeah
this will there'll be a review on this
on the channel before too long can't
wait to see what it can do
anyway thank you for watching uh if you
appreciate the way we do harvard
unboxing consider supporting us on
patreon you can get access to our
discord chat where you can ask us any
questions directly there we've got
monthly live streams it's all happening
here at harbour unboxed
thanks for watching i'm your host steve
and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you